منها واليها نصف موظفين تويتر خرجوا من
الشركه بعد ان خسروا الوظائفهم بقرار من
المالك الجديد للشركه الالماسك واليها
عادوا للحديث عن ما جرى لهم
هاشتاج وانتم وضعه موظفون تويتر السابقون
بعد ان وجدوا انفسهم خارج تويتر الشركه في
الهاشتاج غرد كبار وموظفين وصغارهم عن
غضبهم اذا قرار ماسك وعن تجربتهم
وذكرياتهم مع تويتر مقدمين لبعضهم البعض
رسائل الدعم فيما ذهب اخرون نحو رفع قضيه
على ماسك حتى ان بعضهم اشتكى انه طرد من
قسم وفريق حقوق الانسان بالشركه
عمليه تسريح الموظفين الجماعيه لم تكن
بالخطوه المفاجئه فالاحداث منذ وصول
المالك الجديد الى الشركه متسارعه وغير
متوقعه عدا ان عمليه التسريح ليست جديده
في تاريخ ماسك الاداري ففي تسلا قصه شبيهه
شركه تويتر التزمت الصمطه بشان حجم
التسريحات رئيس اداره السلامه والنزاهه في
الشركه قال ان 15 من موظفي تويتر في فريق
السلامه والنزاهه المسؤول عن منع انتشار
المعلومات الخاطئه والمحتوى الضار ثم
تسريحه
في حين تحدثت وسائل اعلام الاجنبيه بانها
طلبت تصريحا رسميا عن حالات الطرد في
تويتر من مدير التواصل في الشركه لتفاجا
بانه هو ايضا مطرود
الى الماسك الذي لم يتوقف عن التغريد
بغزاره منذ استحواذه على المنصه برر قرار
التسريح بانه لا يوجد خيار عندما تخسر
الشركه اكثر من اربعه ملايين دولار في
اليوم موضحا في تغريده انه تم منح كل من
خرج من الخدمه ثلاثه اشهر تعويضه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه